there's positive reinforcements for
women to get big on social media to get
take off our clothes like we are paid to
do this stuff imagine if men were paid
to watch corn because really social
media is to women as corn is to match so
it's like what if men were paid to do
that stuff what would happen to the men
in society right now it's not paid right
but you see a lot of guys are addicted
to that stuff and it's free and you
could argue that they're only addicted
to it because of the the market of women
like we have the growing increasing
number of male virgins that the left
will just tell you doesn't exist it's
just these weirdos